Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Es wird allerhöchste Zeit, mal wieder nach Italien zu blicken auf die Serie A und da kann es nur einen Gast geben, hier im Rasenfunk. Christian Bernhard von DAZN unter anderem ist wieder hier, jetzt in Rasenfunk Kurzpass 137. Bernie, sei mir sehr herzlich willkommen hier in den Rasenfunk Headquarters.
Hallo Max, wunderschön, hier zu sein.
Ja, ich finde das toll, dass wir wieder über die Serie A sprechen. Mein Gott, uns beiden brannte es unter den Nägeln, das kann man hier an der Stelle mal verraten. Aber ich hatte noch so viele andere Ligen abzufrüstigen. Es ist ein Jammer. Aber jetzt endlich können wir über die Serie A sprechen. Und gibt es denn Themen?
Ich würde sagen, das eine oder andere gibt es, oder? Ich glaube, wir finden das eine oder andere.
Ich glaube, wir finden das eine oder andere. Ich habe unter anderem gelesen, um damit mal gleich zu beginnen, dass Gianluigi Buffon, der ja jetzt UN-Botschafter geworden ist, natürlich, warum auch nicht, hat auf der entsprechenden Veranstaltung gesagt, es gibt nur einen Fall, bei dem ich mir vorstellen könnte, mich auf die Bank zu setzen. Und das ist Juve. Das sind die schönen Geschichten, die nur der Fußball schreibt.
Die schönen Geschichten, die nur der Fußball schreibt, nachdem er ein Jahr sich doch noch verabschiedet hat nach Paris. Ja, ne, klar, keine Frage. Giudic Buffon ist schon wieder so ein bisschen auch nach Hause zurückgekommen. Hat das ja auch so klar kommuniziert, hat ja auch von Anfang an klar gesagt, ich komme hier als Nummer 2, also der kam nicht zurück, um hier quasi Stunk zu machen oder so. Und ist ja auch deshalb zurückgekommen, um so ein bisschen Bindeglied zwischen Sarri, dem neuen Trainer, und dem das Ganze halt einfach auch diese Juve-Welt zu erklären. Und ja, bis jetzt, glaube ich, passt das alles ganz gut.
Und, sagen wir ehrlich, er will halt einfach nochmal die Champions League gewinnen. Und da hat er gesehen, bei dem einen Verein klappt es nicht, der andere ist gut im Rennen. Aber da hast du ja schon, wie ich finde, fast den interessantesten Namen genannt, nämlich Maurizio Sarri. Der ist jetzt bei Juve. Und ich konnte mir das vor der Saison nicht vorstellen, dieser kettenrauchende, gerne auch mal in seinen Äußeren ein bisschen homophobe Trainer mit dem edlen, stylischen Juve. Wie passt es denn jetzt zusammen bisher nach sieben Spieltagen?
Ja, immer besser, muss man sagen. Also am Anfang war es definitiv, er sah es ja auch die ersten Spiele nicht auf der Bank, weil er nach Lungenentzündung elaboriert hat. Und Juve hat zwar die Ergebnisse am Anfang eingefahren, aber ziemlich stotternd in die Saison gestartet. Da waren sehr viele knappe Siege, gegen auch eher kleinere dabei. Also da war noch nicht so viel von dem frühen Sari zu erkennen. Aber jetzt in den letzten Spielen, auch wenn die immer noch sehr knapp waren, also Juve hat jetzt eigentlich, ja wenn man vielleicht Leverkusen ausklammert, eigentlich sich immer auch ergebnismäßig relativ schwer getan. Aber ich finde, man sieht jetzt wirklich von Woche zu Woche immer mehr, ein paar kleine Stückchen Sari-Fußball mehr. Also man hat die schon am Anfang gesehen, da waren das so kleine Farbtupfer. Und jetzt aber sieht man, finde ich, peu à peu immer ein bisschen mehr. Und das beste Beispiel war jetzt am letzten Spieltag das entscheidende 2-1 gegen Inter im Spitzenspiel. Vor dem 2-1 von Higuain gab es 24 Pässe am Stück. Und das, glaube ich, steht schon sehr für das, was Sari, glaube ich, so langfristig bei Juve auch ein bisschen sehen möchte.
Und warum hat es den Wechsel zu ihm gebraucht? Also es lief er jetzt mal, abgesehen davon, dass man die Champions League nicht gewinnen konnte, aber das soll ja auch andere Mannschaften passiert sein in Europa. Warum hat es den Wechsel gebraucht?
Also ich glaube, das war so ein bisschen eine Geschichte. Allegri und Juve waren ewig zusammen und irgendwann nutzt sich das halt auch ein bisschen ab. Also klar, wie du gesagt hast, national gab es ja nichts vorzuwerfen, mehr als die Titel nacheinander einzureihen.
Ja, wir sprechen in jedem Serie A-Kurzpass zuerst über Juve.
Also ich kann es nicht so schlecht glauben. Definitiv. Aber es war halt einfach auch diese Sehnsucht vielleicht ein bisschen da nach, Allegri stand halt doch sehr für sehr pragmatischen Fußball, vielleicht nicht für einen, der jetzt unbedingt ja auch eine klare taktische oder klare visuelle, wie sagt man, ja, irgendwas, Identität gegeben hat, genau. Und ich glaube, da war bei Juve jetzt auch im Management des Sehnsuchts da vielleicht auch ein besonderes Stempel aufzudrücken, also vielleicht nicht mehr nur erfolgreich zu sein, sondern vielleicht auch ein bisschen spielerisch eine kleine Weiterentwicklung zu machen. Und da hat Sarja definitiv in den letzten Jahren davor gezeigt, dass er das kann. Und wie gesagt, also ich glaube, das war auch nichts wirklich Böses. Also es gab auch, es heißt, dass das sollte man vielleicht im Hinterkopf behalten. Also Anjeli soll sehr eng bei Allegri gestanden sein. Also ich glaube, der hätte auch mit dem weiter gemacht. Aber so ein bisschen die neuen frischen Kräfte, Pablo Nedved eben, der immer eine wichtige Funktion einnimmt und auch Paratici, also der Nachfolger von Marotta, der Sportdirektor, die haben dann wohl auf diesen Wechsel gedrängt, dass man dann auch mal so ein bisschen was Neues, auch fußballerisch vielleicht, sich ein bisschen weiterentwickelt. Genau, und da hat man sich für Herrn Sarri entschieden.
Und jetzt dann 4-3-3, viel gutes Positionsspiel, Ballbesitzphasen. Ich habe gesehen, also jetzt im Spiel gegen Inter war Ronaldo relativ weit auf dem Flügel eigentlich, dafür die Baller wahnsinnig zentral. Ist das jetzt so das, was man erwarten kann? Ist das repräsentativ, was man da gegen Inter sehen konnte?
Also es ist, es hat sich sogar schon so eine kleine, also dieses 4-3-3, da kam er logisch auch mit diesem Dogma an, alles so gemeint, oh, ab jetzt gibt es nur noch 4-3-3 bei Juve. Und es ist ganz interessant, er hat es am Anfang auch gemacht, ist auch logischerweise immer noch eines seiner Grundideen. Er hat ja auch von Anfang gesagt, ich möchte ja Ronaldo wieder links kommen lassen, so wie es da mal bei Real zu seinen ganz, ganz großen Zeiten eben war, gemeint, da fand er ihn am stärksten, meint er, ich möchte, dass er es wieder macht. Macht er jetzt auch sehr viel. Was sich jetzt aber ein bisschen verändert hat, er hat so ein bisschen auf dem 4-3-1-2 zuletzt umgestellt, wirklich fast mit einem Zehner. Und den hat teilweise Ramsey gegeben und hat es wirklich sehr gut gemacht in zwei, drei Spielen. Also da merkt man wirklich, dass das wirklich eine, ja, ich glaube, das war so eine Figur, die im Mittelfeld oder als Bindeglied zwischen Mittelfeld und Sturm die Juve sehr gut tut, weil er wirklich, muss ich sagen, wirklich auch – ich bin sehr positiv, wie schnell der sich eingefunden hat, weil er hat auch viel der Vorbereitung verpasst, also hat eigentlich kaum mitgespielt quasi in der Vorbereitung. Und hat da wirklich viele Kurzbässe. Dieses, was Sarri eben sehen will, vieles Tic-Tac, schnelle kleine Wendungen. Und da hast du mit Pjanic, mit Ramsey, jetzt mit Tiballa eben auch, der ja auch so einen verkappten Zehner spielen kann. Da hast du jetzt schon viele Optionen, die übers Zentrum auch, wenn es sehr eng ist, das Ganze spielerisch sehr gut auflösen können.
Aber könnte das jetzt so werden, dass Pjanic dann wieder der Spieler wird, wie – jetzt habe ich es gerade bei Chelsea vergessen – Xorginho. Xorginho, den man halt im Zweifel den Ball gibt, der dann auch 200 Ballkontakte pro Spiel hat, aber ihn nicht ins Angriffstrittel vorbekommt, weil da alles zugestellt ist vom Gegner.
Also im Idealfall soll es dann eben nicht so aussehen, sondern…
Aber gegen Inter war es ein bisschen so, oder? Es war schon ganz schön viel quer, fand ich.
Ja, aber ich glaube, das ist auch das, was Sarri so ein bisschen möchte. Also das war jetzt viel auch dabei. Man sieht dann auch, die Baller kommen viel kurz. Dann wird es nochmal hinten rumgespielt. Ramsey eben wäre da auch eine Option, quasi, der das machen kann. Und Sarri hat das auch im Sommer gesagt. Jorginho war ja nicht nur bei Cezes ein zentraler Spieler, sondern auch bei Napoli. Er hat den ja aus Napoli auch schon mitgenommen. Und er hat gemeint, er möchte auch aus Pjanic so eine Ballverarbeitungsmaschine machen. Er hat gemeint, 150 Ballprojekte pro Spiel. Das wäre so das, was ihm vorschwebt. Und da kommen die so langsam peu a peu hin. Also ich glaube gerade Pjanic ist ideal zum Erklären. Der hat sich in den ersten Spielen – war das eben halt noch nicht so, wie sich Sarri das vorgestellt hat. Und da war Pjanic auch nicht so sehr im Spiel drin. Und jetzt würde ich sagen, von Woche zu Woche ist Pjanic viel zentraler drin. Er hat jetzt auch schon zwei wichtige Tore geschossen. Aber abgesehen davon, man sieht jetzt einfach, dass die Idee, die Sarri hat, schon wirklich nach ein paar Wochen mehr definitiv in den Köpfen drin ist. Und ja, da hat man definitiv Optionen. Weil wie gesagt, wenn du dann vorne Ronaldo als klassischen Stürmer, daneben auch Higuain hast, dann hast du auch physische Präsenz quasi. Oder die Baller kann das ja auch spielen, den zweiten Stürmer vorne. Also sie sind schon relativ schwer auszurechnen.
Das wäre echt eine Geschichte, wenn Sarri den Serie-A-Titel holen würde. Er ist ja der einzige Trainer, der bis, ich glaube, auf die beiden untersten Klassen in Italien in allen Ligen trainiert hat im Laufe seiner Karriere. Unglaublich.
Ja, also wirklich eine beeindruckende Geschichte. Er hat ja früher noch in der Bank gearbeitet. Und relativ spät hat sich dann erst dazu entschieden, irgendwie das als Profi oder überhaupt als Trainer zu versuchen. Also es ist schon wirklich eine beeindruckende Geschichte. Er ist einfach eine Nummer oder ein Typ. Also da sitzt er immer noch jetzt. Er darf ja nicht rauchen auf der Bank. Aber jetzt hat er dann immer so ein kleines Ersatz, ein Zigarettenstück im Mund, so wie den kleinen Stummel. Und darauf beißt er dann rum. Der Mann ist einfach ein Typ, kann man nicht anders sagen.
Okay, ein Thema müssen wir noch ganz kurz bei Juve abhanden, nämlich Embrechan. Weil das bestimmt auch die Hörerinnen und Hörer zum Teil vielleicht mitbekommen haben, dass der sich sehr erbostet darüber gezeigt hat, dass ihm gesagt wurde offenbar von den Juve-Verantwortlichen und auch von Sari, du wirst bei uns auch in der Champions League spielen. Und dann wurde er nicht mal für den Kader für die Champions League gemeldet und hat gesagt, dann wäre ich gerne von Juve weggewechselt. Das ist jetzt der Stand, den ich mitbekommen habe.
Ja, das ist der Stand, den...
Den Embrechan kommen.
Ja, klar, das war eine sehr emotionale Nummer, aber es ist ein sehr gutes Beispiel, um zu zeigen, was für einen Kader Juve in dieser Saison hat. Weil wenn ein Can es nicht auf die Champions-League-Liste schafft, da gibt es noch einen anderen Namen, der nennt sich Mario mit Vornamen, Manzukic mit Nachnamen. Der steht auch nicht auf dieser Champions-League-Liste. Also nur mal zu verdeutlichen, was bei Juve da...
Aus Leistungsgründen? Der war doch auch ein bisschen verletzt.
Nein, das war jetzt nicht das Problem. Es geht ja auch immer bei dieser Champions-League-Liste, du musst ein paar gewisse Anzahl an Spieler aus der eigenen Jugend haben. Und wenn du die nicht hast, dann hast du ein, zwei Plätze weniger, die du sozusagen melden darfst. Und da Juve da relativ wenig Spieler hatte, die sie aus ihrem eigenen Sektor quasi anmelden konnten, mussten die am Ende eben, glaube ich, zwei Plätze weglassen. Und die wären definitiv für Can und Mandzukic gewesen, keine Frage. Aber die mussten dann halt eben Entscheidungen treffen. Und das zeigt jetzt eben, Steffen Freund hat gestern beim Freundschaftsspiel zwischen Argentinien und Argentinien, kam es eben auch auf das Thema Can und da hat er den Satz gesagt, dass er meinte, dass Juve vielleicht momentan den stärksten ausgeglichenen Kader in Europa hat. Ich glaube, das sagt schon einiges aus. Dass es dann Can getroffen hat, ja klar, sehr bitter für ihn. Aber ob das jetzt effektiv dann so war, dass ihm das sehr deutlich kommuniziert wurde. Also ich glaube, dass die alle ein bisschen im Umklaren gelassen haben, weil es war auch im Sommer ein bisschen so eine Frage, wie ist Ramsey eben, wie ist der körperlich da, wie schaut es auch bei Matuidi aus. Weil es ist ja auch ein kleiner, da muss man vielleicht ganz, ganz einen kleinen Exkurs, ich halte mich kurz. Da waren ja auch so ein paar Namen wie Matuidi oder Kedira zum Beispiel. Da hieß es am Anfang vom Sommer, die müssen als Erste weg, weil die haben ja nichts mit Sarri zu tun und das sind so alte Allegri-Jünger. Und wenn du dir jetzt die ersten Spiele anschaust, das waren die, die immer gespielt haben. Also da haben sich auch im Sommer sozusagen die Hierarchien noch mal ein bisschen verschoben. Und gerade Khedira macht eine unfassbar wichtige Rolle da bei Sarri. Da dachten alle als Erstes, ach, der hat doch nichts mit diesem Sarri-Fußball am Hut und war jetzt so mit einer der wichtigsten im Mittelfeld, weil er einfach diese taktische Intelligenz mitbringt.
Das ist doch interessant, oder? Wir diskutieren hier darüber, ob Mats Hummels wieder zurück in die Nationalmannschaft muss und über Khedira wird gar nicht berichtet. Einfach nur, weil er auch außerhalb meines Radars, also ich beziehe mich da ausdrücklich mit ein, Fußball spielt.
Also nochmal, ich finde, wenn man sich bei, man muss sich bei Juve nur mal die Übersicht der Mittelfeldspieler anschauen, da gibt es sehr viele, sehr namhafte. Und wenn man dann schaut, wer da immer gespielt hat, dann ist es eben Sami Khedira. Da sitzt auch so ein Rabioner auf der Punk, der überall sehr krass gehypt wird. Und wie gesagt, da ist noch ein Pentankur, da ist Pjanic, da ist Ramsey, da ist Can. Also das ist schon qualitativ, da gibt es definitiv schwächere Kader. Und Khedira hat da von Anfang an, ja einfach mit seiner fußballerischen Intelligenz, weil es eben beim Sarif Fußball auch darum geht, diese Balance zu halten, weil sie ja doch sehr weit vorschieben, versuchen die Bälle früh zu erobern. Und dann brauchst du einfach spielintelligente Leute im Mittelfeld. Und da hat Khedira dann im Prinzip, in Italien hieß es immer im Juli, ah ja, Khedira und Matyidi werden weggehen, ist nur eine Frage der Zeit. Und seitdem haben die eigentlich immer gespielt. Also das nur, um zu verdeutlichen, dass einfach der Konkurrenzkampf wahnsinnig groß ist. Und dass es dann jetzt so für Pjanic lief, ist logischerweise bitter. Keine Frage, wie jetzt da genau die Kommunikation war. Ich war nicht im Juve-Headquarter, dazu kann ich jetzt nichts sagen. Fakt ist aber, dass er sich auch – er war definitiv, gerade als es so anfing, weit hinten dran. Aber er hat jetzt auch gegen Inter gespielt. Also ich glaube, Pjanic ist auch so eine Kämpfer Natur. Und ich bin mir ganz sicher, dass der auch wieder seine Einsatzzeiten kriegt. Weil das war unter Helege auch so. Da war das vielleicht am Anfang auch noch nicht so. Klar, da war er neu. Aber dann hat er eine tragende Rolle gespielt. Also ich glaube, auch das wird eine der größten Herausforderungen von Sarri werden, dass er diesen Kader auch moderiert. Weil da gibt es mehrere solche Fälle. Und ich glaube, momentan ist es wieder ruhig geworden. Can hat ja, glaube ich, dann auch drei Tage später auch schon wieder das Ganze beschwichtigt.
Ja, aber das kam ja hier in Deutschland wieder kaum an. Also da habe ich auch dann gelesen, jetzt bei meiner Recherche. Aber der Aufreger kam hier an.
Ist schon klar. Aber eben wenn man dann weiter es verfolgen würde, dann sieht man auch, dass das Ganze – Sarri hat sich logisch auch zu ihm geäußert und hat gemeint, er macht das gut im Training. Also ich glaube, das Ganze – noch mal keine Frage, ein Spieler von einer Klasse, von Can, dass das für den völlig überraschend kommt, keine Frage. Aber wie gesagt, wenn man sich einfach mal die anderen Mittelfeldspieler anschaut, dann hätte es die anderen, würde ich sagen, mehr oder weniger genau gleich erwischt, wenn die draußen geblieben wären. Und ja, deswegen nochmal als abrundender Punkt. Das spricht halt sehr für die Tiefe des Juve-Kaders auch.
Absolut. Und da gibt es ja andere Trainer, die sagen, nein, nein, so viele Gucci-Spiele möchte ich gar nicht. Ich kann das nicht mehr moderieren. Und andere planen direkt den Abflug im Winter. Aber das ist jetzt dann vielleicht ein deutsches Thema. Lass uns über Inter Mailand sprechen. Die haben einen historisch guten Saisonstart hingelegt. Die ersten sechs Spiele, sechs Siege. Dann kam es jetzt zum Aufeinandertreffen mit Juve. Und das hat man jetzt knapp zu Hause 1 zu 2 verloren. Inter dennoch natürlich sehr guter Saisonstart. Was hat sich da verändert im Vergleich zum letzten Jahr?
Antonio Conte.
Kann man es wirklich auch faszinieren?
Klarerweise nicht nur. Wir kommen jetzt auch auf den Kader. Klar kamen da auch so Kaliber wie Lukaku. Da konnte es logischerweise auch einer, der dann Spieler kriegt, die vielleicht andere eher nicht so kriegen.
Ich glaube, Transfer-Saldo von 105 Millionen Euro hat man investiert.
Keine Frage. Aber das Um und Auf ist einfach diese Figur Antonio Conte. Und ich muss sagen, auch wenn Inter dieses Spiel jetzt gerade verloren hat, man sieht es ja an der Tabelle, sie sind nur einen Punkt hinten dran. Also alles gut. Und das ist schon beeindruckend, muss ich sagen, auch wenn man diese ersten Spiele so sieht. Also was so ein Conte einfach – ich finde, es gibt keinen besseren Trainer, wenn du sozusagen, gerade auch im großen Verein, der, wo viel Emotionalität rumschwirrt, wenn du mit dem so ein bisschen aus dem Loch rauskommen musst, dann glaube ich, gibt es keine bessere Figur als Antonio Conte. Klar, kann man da Jürgen Klopp, könnte man da sich auch reinwerfen, keine Frage.
Aber bei Conte funktioniert es ja gleich. Also ohne Jürgen Klopp schlecht machen zu wollen, aber er braucht immer seine Anlaufzeit und er braucht seine Spieler. Und Conte kommt, kriegt auch ein paar Spieler, aber er hat auch aus dem, was da war, jetzt diese Mannschaft gewonnen.
Du sagst es ja gerade, und das ist nämlich der entscheidende Punkt. Ich will jetzt auch gar nicht bei Inter unbedingt das Colletto muss reinschmeißen, keine Frage. Aber man muss sich anschauen, er kam damals zu Juve, da war Juve zweimal 7. in Serie, er ist im ersten Jahr Meister geworden. Dann ging er zu Chelsea in ein anderes Land, neue Liga, nicht die leichteste Liga und wird auf Anhieb mit Chelsea Meister. Das ist einer, der kann einfach von Anfang an so ein brutales Feuer entfachen. Und Inter ist da wie gemacht dafür, für diese Symbiose, weil Inter lechts klarerweise seit Jahren nach Erfolgen. Ich glaube, wenn ich das recht in Erinnerung habe, Inter war in den letzten sechs oder sieben Jahren nie besser als Dritter. Das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Also für den Namen einfach und das Renommee von Inter. Du hattest die letzten Jahre immer Spieler-Namen da, auch große Namen, immer wieder ein bisschen Hoffnung. Du hattest auch Spalletti, der jetzt zuletzt alles andere als ein schlechter Trainer ist. Aber du siehst einfach, dass Conte da nochmal eine andere Nummer ist, weil der einfach reinkommt und da alle von einem Moment auf den anderen wissen, wenn wir das jetzt machen, was dieser Mann uns sagt, dafür gibt es sehr viele Beispiele in der Nationalmannschaft. Da haben wir auch mal angesprochen, der hat Spanien, Belgien und so geschlagen. Da kannten glaube ich viele 7 oder 8 Stammspieler nicht. Also da merkst du einfach, Conte ist einer, der kann das einfach. Da kommt viel über Emotionen, viel über Leidenschaft. Und das Ergebnis sieht man jetzt mit diesem Start hier.
Faszinierend. Also ich habe nochmal gerade nachgeguckt, die letzte Platzierung unter den ersten zwei, also zweiter war man zuletzt 2010, 2011.
Genau.
Okay, also das eine ist der Trainer, der hat jetzt die Spieler angezündet. Welche Spieler hat er denn besonders angezündet? Auf wen muss ich da gucken bei Inter?
Klar, der erste Name, der auffällt, ist da Lukaku, keine Frage. Hat sehr viel Geld gekostet, war logisch auch so ein Signaltransfer, um nochmal zu zeigen, Hallo, Inter will jetzt wirklich auch nochmal ganz groß angreifen.
Was mich ehrlich gesagt von außen betrachtet ein bisschen gewundert hat, dass Romelu Lukaku, ohne ihm persönlich zu nahe treten zu wollen, aber dass dieser Transfer so eine Bedeutung hatte, so wie ich es wahrgenommen hatte, auch Italienweit. Also es wurde ja sehr viel drüber berichtet, kommt er nicht. Es schien mir so, neben Matthias de Ligt, der Transfer gewesen zu sein. Das hat mich ein bisschen überrascht, weil Romelu Lukaku definitiv ein guter Spieler ist, aber für mich jetzt auf anderen Ebenen steht, wie zum Beispiel Matthias de Ligt. Der hat viel jünger ist und viel mehr Potenzial noch zeigt.
Also ich glaube, zum einen hat da logisch die Summe eine Rolle gespielt. Da ist ja die Rede von 75 Millionen, glaube ich, in dem Bereich. Also was ja schon erstmal die Ansage auch ist. Und zum anderen, wenn man sich seine Torbilanz anschaut, dann ist die schon alles andere als verkehrt. Jetzt hatte ja klar in dem Jahr davor bei Manchester oder bei United gab es das eine oder andere Problem. Das war ja nicht der einzige, sagen wir mal so. Aber wenn du dir die Quote auch in der Nationalmannschaft anschaust und vor allen Dingen, und da schließt sich auch wieder der Gleis zu Conte. Conte wollte Lukaku schon zu Juve zeiten und Conte wollte Lukaku auch schon zu Chelsea zeiten. Also das ist so ein… Conte hat auch einfach das Gespür dafür, Leuten dieses Gefühl zu vermitteln, ich will dich unbedingt. Und wenn ich dich kriege, dann baue ich um dich herum was auf. Und das hat Lukaku auch von Anfang an klar gemacht, dass da Conte anscheinend ein Faktor war, denn Juve war auch im Rennen. Also da hieß es, dass Juve auch…
Stimmt, die haben ja keine Stürmer. Die Baller, Romano, Mancik, Higuain…
Da waren wir ja wirklich nicht, mit wem man abstellen soll. Nein, deswegen klar, Signaltransfer ja. Aber ich würde sagen, der interessanteste Spieler, der vielleicht auch ein bisschen unter dem Radar ist, weil er halt einfach nicht so bekannt ist, der ersten Wochen war Stefano Sensi. Der kam von Sassuolo, auch logisch nicht unbedingt von einem großen Verein. Aber es ist wirklich beeindruckend, wie der war. Der war auch davor schon. Mancini hat den schon auch in die Nationalmannschaft einberufen. Er hat jetzt relativ schnell so den Stempel, von Art her, ein kleiner Iniesta bekommen. Also sehr wendiger, mittelfeldspieliger, sehr gute Übersicht, sehr gute Technik. Und da muss ich sagen, der hat sich wirklich, das war von Sommer an auch schon die ersten Vorbereitungsspielen, der hat sich mit Brosewitsch perfekt gefunden. Und hat da wirklich jetzt eine zweite Option im Mittelfeld. Also wirklich hat gleich alle Standards geschlagen, sau viele Tore vorbereitet, auch schon selber Tore geschossen. So eine spielerische Leichtigkeit reingebracht, wo ich echt sagen muss, Respekt vor allen Dingen. Weil es ist eine Sache, wenn du in San Siro für Inter spielst, da ist Druck drauf. Also so ein Stadion kann auch mal, das sind auch schon Spieler, also ich will jetzt nicht zerbrochen daran sagen, aber das ist schon was anders, als wenn du dann vielleicht in einem kleineren Stadion einfach aufläufst. Und das hat er weggesteckt, als hätte er immer schon bei einer großen Mannschaft gespielt. Und deswegen würde ich sagen, so ein bisschen das Bild dieses neuen Inters, würde ich fast sagen, ist San Si in diesen ersten Wochen.
Hat ja auch schon dreimal getroffen und zwei Tore vorbereitet. Da wird dann wahrscheinlich auch Borussia Dortmund sich auf einiges freuen können, mit dem man ja in der Gruppe ist. Es ist Lawea Prag und Barca sind die anderen beiden Mannschaften. Jetzt kommt es ja dann auch zum Aufeinandertreffen nach der Länderspielpause. Guten heißer Tanz!
Ja, ich finde, das ist eine mega Gruppe. Inter muss da jetzt logisch auch schauen, dass sie punkten. Also gerade das Barca-Spiel war aber auch so eine Sache. Das darf man nicht vergessen. In der Inter-Jube-Woche war ja davor das Inter-Barca-Spiel. Es hat Inter lang nicht mehr gehabt, dass sie wirklich in so einem Zeitraum so zwei hochklassige Spiele hatten. Und klar, jetzt haben sie zwar beide verloren, kann man am Ende sagen.
Beide mit 1 zu 2?
Ja, aber gerade auch in Barcelona. Also da war schon von Inter-Seite ordentlich was los. Also die waren vorne, hatten auch gute Möglichkeiten aufs 2-0. Und ich sag mal so, klar, müssen wir auch nicht drüber reden. Barca ist vielleicht momentan auch nicht das Barca, das vielleicht die letzten Jahre so war. Aber im Camp Nou würde ich schon mal sagen, es ist nochmal eine andere Nummer als auch Barca auswärts. Und deswegen, auch wenn Inter jetzt aus dieser Woche mit 0 Punkten rausgegangen ist, fand ich doch, war das auch eine Woche, dass sie gezeigt haben, dass definitiv in der Saison mit denen zu rechnen ist. Auch ganz weit oben und auch um Juve sehr lange dran zu bleiben, vielleicht sogar nicht nur dran zu bleiben. Traue ich Ihnen zu.
Faszinierend, ja, da werde ich genau hingucken. Ich bin ja bei Conte immer noch, das erste Jahr unter Conte ist immer geil. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie das zweite Jahr unter ihm wird, aber ich will jetzt nicht auch gleich nur unten, bringt ja nichts. Aber es war definitiv auch schon, also es war ein gutes Spiel bei Barca, da habe ich Teile von gesehen, und beim Juvispiel konnte ich auch Teile sehen. Das hatte definitiv Hand und Fuß und war auch einfach sehr abgeklärt fast schon.
Abgeklärt und was einfach das entscheidende Punkt ist, du hast, konnte, hat, ist eine kleine nette Anekdote, dass am ersten Spieltag gegen Lecce, was ich auch bei der Zone Co. kommentieren durfte, wo sie 4-0 gewonnen haben, wo gleich eben diese Euphorie aufkam, da hat er auf der Pressekonferenz danach den Journalisten seine Smartwatch gezeigt, wo die, seine Schritte oder seine Kilometer aufgezeichnet werden und erst während dem Spiel 8 Kilometer gelaufen. In der Mixed Zone.
Nicht schlecht.
Sorry, in der Coaching Zone. Also nur um zu zeigen, der geht da draußen mit. Und die Spieler wissen halt, also dieses Spiel ist halt einfach viel emotionaler. Und als Ballette war das sehr viel verwalten, der Fußball. Da waren ja auch schon sehr gute Fußballer da. Da ist ja sehr viel Qualität war ja die letzten Jahre auch da. Aber jetzt hast du halt das Gefühl, die wissen da draußen ist einer. Und wir müssen immer dieses, ja, Intensität, Leidenschaft, das muss da sein. Und dass Qualität da ist, ist ja keine Frage bei Inter. Und wenn du das zusammenkriegst und das kriegt, Konter eben zusammen, dann hast du eine Mannschaft, die sehr gefährlich werden kann.
Und du hast ja auch mit Godin zum Beispiel hinten drin ein, wo man das Gefühl hat, da passt der Trainer auch genau zum Spieler.
Also ich glaube, für einen Godin war die Umstellung von Herrn Simeone zu Herrn Konter oder von Athletic zu Inter nicht so groß wie vielleicht zu anderen Vereinen. Genau. Und dann bringt er einfach seine brutale Erfahrung mit. Also ja, da ist schon Tiefe auch im Kader da. Jetzt hast du noch einen Sanchez, der vorne so als dritter Stürmer rumläuft oder so. Also da ist, wie gesagt, Qualität ist da. Und jetzt hast du aber auch einen vorne weg mit Konter, der das Ganze nochmal so emotional anzünden kann. Und deswegen sehr gefährliche Mischung, würde ich sagen, bei Inter.
Hoffentlich haben wir es jetzt nicht zerredet, wenn wir so viel Zeit auf Inter verwenden. Aber wir werden es einfach beobachten. Wenn man sich die vorderen Tabellenplätze anguckt, dann überrascht einen nicht alles in Italien. Eine Mannschaft fehlt, über die werden wir dann gleich noch sprechen. Auf Platz 3 aktuell Atalanta Bergamo. Und was mich vor allem überrascht hat, ist, wie wenige Niederlagen viele Mannschaften erst haben. Also sowohl die Roma als auch Bergamo als auch Inter und sowieso Juve, die noch ungeschlagen sind, erst eine Niederlage in dieser Saison. War denn der Saisonstart jetzt von Bergamo auch so dominant, wie sich das liest?
Sie haben schon wieder den besten Angriff der Liga. Was jetzt ja auch nicht so ohne ist, quasi. Also ich finde es beeindruckend, weil sie hatten ja wirklich diese Rückschläge in der Champions League. Sie sind ja mit dieser riesen Euphorie da reingegangen, in diese überragende letzte Saison. Dann fängst du ins Zagreb an und fährst mit einem 4-0 nach Hause. Also sie haben mit viel gerechnet, aber mit dem ganz sicher nicht. Und umso beeindruckender finde ich, wie sie sich jetzt einfach in der Liga da das abgeschüttelt haben. Also es ist schon echt toll. Sie haben es ja geschafft, Gott sei Dank nach letzter Saison mehr oder weniger fast alles zusammenzuhalten. Sie haben eigentlich mehr oder weniger keinen der ganz, ganz Wichtigen verloren. Und sie haben sogar vorne noch mit Muriel, also mit dem kolumbianischen Nationalstürmer, nochmal Qualität dazugeholt. Ja, und das zeigt sich jetzt in den ersten Spielen. Also Gasparini und die Mannschaft kennen sich ganz genau. Und in der Liga ist es wirklich beeindruckend. Die schweben da auf ihrer Welle weiter, knipsen, was das Zeug hält. Und spielen diesen erfrischenden, laufstarken, dynamischen Fußball. Gomez spielt schon jetzt wieder überragend, verbindet da vorne das ganze Zapata, macht einfach da weiter, wo er letztes Jahr aufgehört hat. Also es ist schon stark, wie die sich da einfach fast, wie selbstverständlich jetzt, auf ganz vorne eingenistet haben. Also eben die liegen da zwischen Inter und Neapolits, wären die da immer schon gewesen. Und schon echt toll, muss ich sagen, dass die halt auch dieses, wie gesagt, weil letztes Jahr war dann einfach so viel über Euphorie getragen, ist ja klar, ist keine Frage. Und es scheint jetzt, als wäre da mehr als nur Euphorie dahinter, sondern als wäre da wirklich auch dieses Konzept und diese Selbstsicherheit, glaube ich, mittlerweile auch zu sagen, ja gut, wir sehen uns jetzt als eine Mannschaft, die da einfach um die ersten vier Plätze ganz klipp und klar mitspielen will und kann. Und deswegen, Chapeau, wie die da weiter marschieren einfach.
Ist die Abwehr da ein Thema? Das war ja auch schon in der letzten Saison so, also eher mal 3 zu 2 als 1 zu 0. Jetzt auch schon zehn Tore nach sieben Spieltagen, das ist völlig okay. Aber wenn ich mir eben angucke, in Zagreb 0-4 verloren, gegen Donn jetzt zu Hause dann in der Champions League, das zweite Champions-League-Spiel auch verloren, 1 zu 2. Hängt das mit der Abwehr zusammen oder gibt es dafür andere Gründe?
Also ich glaube, dass Batalanta so ein ganzheitlicher Ansatz ist. Also dieses intensive, manchmal vielleicht Serie A-untypische Spiel, immer drauf, immer die Zweikämpfe suchen. Das birgt logischerweise auch die Risiken, dass du dann hin und wieder hinten ein paar Lücken mehr hast. Ich glaube, das ist einfach eingepreist. Sie haben logischerweise eine Nummer, die sie schon verkraften mussten. Sie wollten im Sommer einen erfahrenen Innenverteidiger zuhauen und haben sich dann für Skrittl entschieden, ex Liverpool. Der war dann auch da und war aber nach zehn Tagen wieder weg, weil er sich unwohl gefühlt hat, aber anscheinend seine Familie das Ganze nicht mittragen wollte. Dann haben sie ganz kurz vor Knapp Simon Kehr als Tessener-Satz geholt. Der soll jetzt einfach noch ein bisschen internationale Erfahrungen mit reinbringen. Aber nochmal, ich würde es bei Atalanta nicht auf einzelne Mannschaftsteile setzen, sondern es ist einfach ein Konstrukt, das sehr dynamisch agiert als Ganzes, sowohl nach vorne als auch nach hinten. Und ja, Gasperini hat das immer wieder auch gesagt, lieber mal ein 3-2 als ein 1-0. Also das ist auch einer, der da jetzt nicht verrückt wird. Solange die da vorne knipsen, glaube ich, können sie sich auch das eine oder andere Gegentor mehr leisten als die Konkurrenz.
Und dann haben wir einen Spieler, über den müssen wir immer sprechen, wenn wir bei Atalanta sprechen, nämlich Robin Gosens. Den deutschen Dienst von Atalanta, der auch schon drei Tore gemacht hat, eins vorbereitet. Das liest sich für mich, ohne dass ich jetzt was gesehen hätte, ehrlicherweise, wie ein guter Saisonstart und dass er da eine wichtige Rolle spielt.
Definitiv. Und da sind wir wieder beim Punkt. Das sind einfach diese Automatismen, die unter Gasperini halt jetzt schon das dritte Jahr oder greifen. Die wissen ganz genau, was sie zu tun haben. Das haben wir, glaube ich, letztes Jahr auch schon mal besprochen. Gerade auch über Außen, da passiert wahnsinnig viel, hast du Gosens auf der einen Seite, Hatteboer, den holländischen Nationalspieler auf der anderen. Also da wird marschiert, die gehen vorne mit rein. Der Klassiker ist eigentlich immer, wenn ein Angriff über rechts kommt, dann wirst du immer Gosens auch im Strafraum drin sehen, der von links rein zieht. Also da hast du eine wahnsinnig gute Strafraumbesetzung, also da turnen unter Anführungszeichen vorne nicht nur die Stürme rum, sondern gibt es immer Unterstützung von hinten auch. Wenn Gosens über links kommt, dann wirst du oft den Querpass sehen, wo Hatteboer reinzieht. Also ja, das ist sehr schön anzuschauen. Und es ist schade, dass sie jetzt wirklich in der Champions League, gerade auch dieses 2-1 in der Nachspielzeit, haben sie das ja kassiert gegen Donetsk. Das ist jetzt logisch, wenn du nach zwei Spieltagen in der Gruppe mit Nullpunkten da stehst, dann ist das klarerweise, da muss man nicht drüber reden. Jetzt wird es sehr, sehr schwierig, kein Thema. Aber trotzdem, ich würde den nicht komplett abschreiben, weil die nicht, also dieser Sargrap-Spiel, das war definitiv so ein emotionaler Ausrutscher. Da war glaube ich einfach zu viel Erwartung, zu viel Euphorie da. Dann denkst du dir vielleicht auch, ach komm, Sargrap. Und dann ging es halt gewaltig in die Hose. Aber nochmal, ich glaube nicht, dass die sich da von ihrem Weg abbringen lassen. Und ja, Gosens ist da definitiv einer, der da genau in diesem Konzert weiterhin genau weiß, was er zu machen hat und fest drin ist. Und ein fester Teil dieses Konstruktes.
Aber könnte Gosens denn eigentlich auch für die deutsche Nationalmannschaft spielen oder hat er sich für den niederländischen entschieden?
Also meines Wissens nach ist der sowieso noch frei, weil er in dem Sinn – genau, er hat noch kein Spiel gemacht. Genau. Also von dem her wüsste ich jetzt nicht, dass da was prinzipiell dagegen sprechen.
Ich finde das insofern erstaunlich, weil halt bei Deutschland gerade Spiele ausfallen wie Reife Äpfel vom Baum. Also auch so jahreszeitmäßig. Also im Oktober fallen sie wirklich alle runter. Und der Name Gosens nicht einmal gefallen ist. Das finde ich einfach nur interessant.
Ich glaube, er hat auch gerade in Deutschland nicht unbedingt ein großes Standing. Aber warum? Ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Da wären wir halt wieder beim Punkt. Vielleicht sind manchmal die anderen Ligen nicht so im Fokus, wie sie es vielleicht gehören.
Für uns ist das ja okay. Aber für die DFB und für Journalisten vor Ort, da könnte man... Also wie gesagt, ich musste jetzt auch nachgucken. Hat er überhaupt so ein Länderspiel gemacht? Also ich wusste es auch nicht. Ich will jetzt nicht so tun, als ob ich jetzt hier der Riesen Robin Gossens Intimus wäre. Aber ich finde es halt interessant, weil der spielt auf dem linken Flügel, der kann alle Positionen spielen, spielt offensiv sehr gut, wie du es jetzt beschrieben hast.
Ja und vor allen Dingen spielt er jetzt halt einfach auch schon seit zwei Saisonen mit seiner Mannschaft auf einem sehr hohen Niveau.
International, genau.
Genau, international, davor ist schon Europa League. Also ja, vielleicht sollte man da ein kleines Auge mal zumindest mal drauf werfen.
Okay, also wenn, dann habt ihr es hier zuerst gehört. Gut, dann lass uns über Nea Ape sprechen. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie viel sich da jetzt verändert hat, wie bemerkenswert bisher der Saison oft hat für Nea Ape war. Ordne es mal ein für mich.
Ja, eigentlich hat sich vom Kader her, sich nochmal mehr zum Positiven verändert. Also Napoli hat auch in der Saison wirklich in der Breite nochmal ziemlich drauf gepackt, wenn man sich allein die Offensive anschaut. Also die war ja schon in den letzten Jahren alles andere als verkehrt. Und jetzt hast du noch einen Lorente und einen Lozano dazu bekommen, den man in Deutschland ja auch noch ein bisschen kennt.
Von der WM 280.
Genau, zum Beispiel. Und du hast nichts verloren. Da vorne sind immer noch die Mieligs, die Mertens, die Cali-Horns, die Insinues da. Also in der Breite, würde ich sagen, hat Neapel auch den stärksten Kader der letzten Jahre. Hinten in der Defensive ist mit Manolas noch mal so eine zweite Mauer neben Koulibaly dazugekommen, der wirklich auch bei der Roma eher eine tragende Rolle gespielt hat. Und wo ich auch fest davon überzeugt bin, auch wenn das am Anfang jetzt vielleicht noch nicht so ganz rund läuft, dass der mit Koulibaly mal eine richtig schöne Mauer bilden wird über den Verlauf der Saison, weil die zwei in der Mitte im Zentrum, muss ich sagen, da sehe ich nicht wahnsinnig viel bessere Innenverteidiger-Dos, auch europaweit auf dem Papier rumlaufen. Also das ist schon sehr viel Qualität. Und von dem her, muss ich sagen, bin ich ein kleines bisschen enttäuscht vom Saisonstart von Neapel, weil sie halt einfach wieder schon wieder mal so ganz einige blöde Punkte liegen haben lassen. Ich meine, dass du dieses erste wilde Spiel gegen Juve da am zweiten Spieltag 4-3 noch verlierst, das ist ein völlig verrücktes Spiel im Prinzip. War, sage ich mal, kann passieren in Turin, keine Frage. Aber wenn du dann halt eben anfängst, daheim gegen Kaljeri zu verlieren 0-1. In Turin kannst du auch Punkte liegen lassen, also gegen Turin. Das ist auch okay, mal unentschieden. Aber es ist halt so eine Sache. Und jetzt, wenn du dir die Tabelle anschaust, sind halt auch schon wieder sechs Punkte Rückstand. Also es geht dann halt immer schnell, weil Juve dann einfach trotzdem in dem Maschinenmodus drin ist, sage ich mal, und einfach die Dinger holt. Weil nochmal, Juve war in den ersten Spieltagen nicht überzeugender als Neapel. Aber Juve hat die Punkte trotzdem geholt. Und jetzt läufst du halt wieder schön hinterher, hast sechs Punkte Rückstand. Ja, ich hätte mir gewünscht, dass Neapel da so ein bisschen wie Inter auch ein bisschen enger dran ist, sozusagen.
Ein bisschen läuft es wirklich wie immer bei Neapel, ja auch in der Champions League. Gegen Liverpool gewonnen, klar, kennen wir ja schon aus dem letzten Jahr zu Hause, kein Problem, aber dann in Gang 0 zu 0.
Ja, es ist schwer zu erklären, wobei gut, dass du das Liverpool-Spiel ansprichst, weil das zeigt eben wieder, in so besonderen Momenten, in den einzelnen Spielen, ist Neapel wirklich eine Pracht. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das Spiel gesehen hast, ich fand diese erste halbe Stunde von Napoli gegen Liverpool, ich dachte mir, wo soll das hinführen? Also was da an Tempo und dann Intensität drin war, klar von Liverpool kennt man das jetzt, und gerade mit den drei da vorne.
Ja, aber dass das mit Ansage nochmal passiert.
Genau, die wussten ja ganz genau, was das Sache ist. Genau, und dann kommen die wieder dahin. Das ist einfach noch schlimmer als das. Deswegen zeigt ja dieses unfassbare Potenzial, das diese Mannschaft hat. Und nochmal, Ancelotti hat da ja auch viel aus dem letzten Jahr. Die Mannschaft kennt sich, darf man ja auch nicht vergessen. Wenn du dir die ersten Mannschaften anschaust, oder die großen Namen, dann ist Napoli die einzige Mannschaft, die den gleichen Trainer in Italien hat wie letzte Saison. Also die haben wirklich von Anfang an eigentlich auch, sind die auf einer, sag ich mal, auf einer besseren Kennenlernbasis gestartet, als jetzt Inter mit konnte, als Sarri mit Juve, als Milan, wo wir auch noch dazukommen, also auch als die Roma, wo ihr auch mit von Seca neuer Trainer ist. Und dafür nochmal, es ist jetzt nicht, dass Napoli unterirdisch war, die ersten Spiele, keine Frage. Aber sie haben halt einfach wieder schon 6 Punkte Rückstand. Und das aufzuholen gegen eine Mannschaft gerade wie Juve, wo du das Gefühl hast, die lassen kaum Punkte, ja, ist halt einfach schwierig.
Und bei einer Sache bin ich noch hellhörig geworden, die du gesagt hast. Also ich habe ja auch gesehen, dass Napoli sehr viel investiert hat. Und du hast ja auch schon die Namen genannt, die da gekommen sind. War Carlo Ancelotti nicht in München noch der Trainer, der gesagt hat, also mehr als 23 Kaderspieler brauche ich nicht, weil das ist nicht händelbar? Wurde das nicht damals hier so kommuniziert von Leuten, die nicht Carlo Ancelotti hießen?
Vielleicht wurde es damals so kommuniziert. Also ich glaube, wenn ich an den Trainer Carlo Ancelotti denke, dann habe ich da immer als Erstes im Gefühl, das sehe ich sowohl in Madrid bei Real als auch bei Chelsea als auch bei Paris. Und da muss man dann vielleicht diese Bayern-Zeit einfach ein bisschen in Klammer setzen. War er für mich eigentlich immer der, der es sehr gut geschafft hat, große Kader, namhafte Kader und auch Spieler mit vielleicht ein bisschen größeren Egos als andere sehr gut zu moderieren. Also von dem her war das glaube ich in Neapel kein Thema. Im Gegenteil, er hat da letzte Saison auch immer wieder so zwischen den Zeilen mal fallen lassen. Ja, wir brauchen noch ein bisschen was, um wirklich ganz, ganz, um wirklich auch mit Juve vielleicht ganz auf Augenhöhe auch kadertechnisch sein zu können und dass der Laurent ist logisch sehr eng mit Ancelotti ist und von Anfang an ja auch klargemacht hat, oh für diesen Trainer würde ich alles machen. Deswegen hat sich das jetzt auch im Sommer dann eben in Neuverpflichtungen, wie sagt man, ja dargelegt und niedergeschlagen. Und nochmal, das ist ja auch alle, Napoli wird auch weiterhin, die haben die Qualität, die haben die spielerischen Möglichkeiten, nur ich hatte halt gehofft, dass sie vielleicht und die allerersten Spiele gingen auch in die Richtung, die hatten ja zum Beispiel auch dieses wilde Spiel am Anfang in Florenz. Das wäre so ein Klassiker gewesen, dass sie da auch Punkte liegen haben, haben sie da.
4-3 war das.
Genau, am Ende gewinnen sie es noch, 4-3. Da dachte ich mir, schau an, wenn sie das diese Saison schaffen, dass sie diese, wo sie sonst immer mal wieder mal 0-0 eingestreut haben. Dann dachte ich mir am Anfang, okay, das ist die Saison anders, aber es ist leider auch schon 2-3 Mal wieder passiert. Und ich hoffe, dass sie das rauskriegen, weil dann sind die definitiv auch ein Kandidat, um wirklich auch ganz lang wieder bei Juve dabei bleiben zu können. Keine Frage.
Gut, dann tun wir jetzt etwas, das darf man nur machen, wenn man als Deutsche über die Serie A spricht. Wir sprechen einfach beide Römervereine gleichzeitig. Die kommen nämlich jetzt in der Tabelle nacheinander. Und als wir vorhin über Conte gesprochen haben, habe ich das noch richtig in Erinnerung, dass es damals bei der Roma wahnsinnig viele Gerüchte um Conte gab. Und das hat sich jetzt ja aber nicht bestätigt. Jetzt hat man von Secker bekommen.
Ja, aber es waren nicht nur Gerüchte, sondern Conte hat auch irgendwann gesagt, also die Roma ist sehr entschieden auch an ihn herangetreten. Also als er noch eben frei war quasi, als er auch schon hinterher so rumgewabert ist, als auch Juve ein bisschen rumgewabert ist, muss man ja auch ehrlicherweise sagen. Und er hat damals gesagt, er hat es im Prinzip jetzt bei Inter andersrum. Er hat gemeint, er muss irgendwo hinkommen. Er braucht nicht viel Garantie, hat er gemeint, aber er will zumindest 1% Wahrscheinlichkeit haben, dass er gleich Erfolg haben kann. Und das hat er halt da bei der Roma anscheinend nicht gesehen. Ja, kann man jetzt, klar kann man sagen, aber vielleicht hat er nicht ganz unrecht. Aber mit von Seca muss ich sagen, haben sie jetzt, was zumindest die ersten Spiele anzeigen, auch sich einen geangelt, also die Roma in den ersten Spieltagen war wirklich sehr, sehr hübsch anzuschauen. Also wirklich gerade nach vorne. Edin Dzeko, überragender Saisonstart wieder. Das war ja auch so ein Name. Den wollte Conte unbedingt zu Inter auch. Da dachte man im Juli eigentlich auch, das ist nur eine Frage der Zeit, bis der auch unterschreibt. Zusammen mit Lukaku. Conte wollte da wirklich von Anfang an groß aufrüsten.
Ja, Wahnsinn.
Und dann hat er aber im Prinzip, hat er dann plötzlich so eine Kehrtwende gemacht und hat gesagt, er bekennt sich trotzdem zu Roma und er bleibt jetzt bei der Roma. Und das war ein bisschen überraschend. Also das hat das Roma-Umfeld nochmal extrem emotionalisiert. Und hat einen Bomben-Saisonstart hingelegt. Ganz viele wichtige Tore schon geschossen. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir schon darüber gesprochen haben, ich bin immer noch, ich muss sagen, ich bin ein riesen J.K.O.-Fan, immer noch. Ich glaube, der ist auch mittlerweile klar. Er hat jetzt sein Alter, keine Frage.
Kein 30 ist er?
Kein Ding, aber wenn man sich mal ein komplettes Roma-Spiel anschaut, ich finde es schon wirklich faszinierend einfach, wie viele Bälle der ansaugt, wie viele Bälle der festmacht. Den kannst du in allen Höhen anspielen. Der verarbeitet die Bälle. Im Idealfall knipsert er dir dann vorne eben auch die Buden weg. Also, ich muss schon sagen, er ist schon wirklich ein sehr, sehr, sehr kompletter, immer noch beeindruckend starker Mittelstürmer. Und ist jetzt so dieser Kopf einfach dieser neuen Roma-Mannschaft, sage ich mal.
Ja, absolut. Und es geht halt so ein bisschen unter, weil wir haben ihn halt noch bei Wolfsburg gesehen, aber das war halt der frühe JKO und da war er ja schon sehr, sehr gut. Aber wenn man sich einfach anguckt, was der für Statistiken abgerissen hat, ist einfach faszinierend. Also dann später bei Manchester City, da lief es nicht immer, aber hat ja auch zwei Saisons, wo er einmal 14 Treffer, einmal 16 Treffer gemacht hat. Und dann bei der Roma, da hat es halt richtig angefangen. Da gibt es halt einfach eine Saison mit 29 Treffern und 9 Vorlagen. Und da hat man noch drüber gesprochen, das war jetzt vor zwei Jahren. Aber so ein bisschen aus dem Blickfeld gerät das halt einfach, weil du nicht mehr täglich Kicken siehst.
Nee, ist wirklich beeindruckend. Zum Beispiel, wenn man sich die letzte Saison anschaut, da waren die Zahlen jetzt nicht mehr, also die Torzahlen oder Scoringzahlen nicht mehr so überragend. Aber auch da, nochmal, man muss sich nur ein Spiel mal anschauen, wie wichtig der einfach ist, auch wenn er nicht trifft. Weil der ist einfach so ein Offensivterminal, den kannst du in allen Positionen anspielen. Der hilft dir dann logischerweise, der macht die Pelle fest, hilft dann, dass die anderen aufrücken, öffnet dann nochmal mit dem Rücken zum Tor auch, nimmt dir die Außenstürmer mit. Also das ist schon wirklich, selbst wenn er nicht trifft, ist er extrem wichtig. Und jetzt, wie er jetzt in diesem Saisonstart, wenn er auch wieder seine Tore liefert, und da waren jetzt wirklich auch schon Wichtige dabei, so knappe Dinger, das 1-0 und so, dann ist das einfach, ja, einfach ein brutal kompletter Mittelstürmer.
Wir werden ihn ja auch noch näher beobachten können, denn die Roma ist ja in einer Europa League Gruppe mit Borussia Mönchengladbach. Das wird jetzt auch dann das nächste Spiel sein am 24.
Genau. Und um das nochmal bei der Roma eben, wie gesagt, unser Fonseca wirklich schon sehr ansehnlich nach vorne, viel Schwung drin, sehr gutes Offensivspiel. Miki Darin kam jetzt auch noch dazu. Also die haben auch vorne Qualität. Auch so diese Kloywerd, der in der zweiten Saison ist, der jetzt deutlich stabiler wirkt. Der Junge Türke, der jetzt gerade verletzt ist, aber der auch einen guten Saisonstart hatte. Pellegrini, Lorenzo Pellegrini. Italienische Nationalspiel hat einen richtig guten Start gehabt, hat jetzt schon vier Vorlagen, wird auch so ein bisschen. Der wurde von Totti ja auch geadelt bei dieser legendären Totti Abschiedspressekonferenz. Also das ist auch einer, der da aus dem Mittelfeld hinten raus für Akzente setzt. Also nach vorne ist das Ganze sehr anzündig bei der Roma schon.
Und Chris Moorling spielt ja inzwischen bei der Roma. Das ist noch so ein Name, da muss man sich noch, man muss dann immer die Namen neuen vereinen zuordnen. So wie man bei Mkhitaryan zuerst an Arsene denkt, muss man bei Chris Moorling jetzt auch sich die Roma in den Kopf holen. Wie läuft es denn dagegen bei Lazio? Giro Immobile, der knipst wie immer, habe ich gesehen, führt schon wieder alle Listen an.
Seit Herr Immobile wieder in Rom ist, gibt es eigentlich nur eine Option, die heißt Tor. Das gab jetzt auch vor zwei Spielen mal eine kleine Szene, da hat er getroffen, wurde ausgewechselt, war sehr opos darüber, hat dann Richtung Trainerin Sagi, war nicht so nett, der Gesten öffentlich gezeigt, das war dann auch gleich ein Riesenthema.
Und wie geht Pippo Insagi mit so etwas um? Nicht Pippo, Simone Insagi.
Ja, aber auch Simone Insagi war ein Stürmer.
Ja, das stimmt, ja.
Das Schöne ist, der geht so um, dass das intern geregelt wurde, also wurde er nicht öffentlich groß gerügt, hat sich auch entschuldigt und hat dem Spiel darauf getroffen und ist beim Torjubel zu Insagi hingelaufen und hat ihn umarmt.
Ach, solche Geschichten.
Insagi schafft es wirklich auch, also der kleine Insagi schafft es wirklich auch, so eine Wohlfühladmosphäre gerade für die Stürmer herzustellen. Und da wären wir ja wieder auch – die Lazio ist wieder nach vorne. Das kann man sehr gut anschauen.
13 Tore nach 7 Spielen.
Ja, ja, da ist Schwung drin, da ist eben mit Korea auch, der jetzt neben dem Mobile Yacht spielt. Du hast Luis Alberto eben dahinter, den Spanier. Milinkovic, Savic ist wieder präsenter als noch in der letzten Saison. Also das ist auch sehr, sehr ansehnlich. Es fehlt manchmal auch so ein bisschen der Balance vielleicht. Aber ich glaube, dass die Lazio auch – und man sieht es jetzt wieder, wenn man sich das Rennen anschaut – ich dachte vor der Saison – und ich bleibe auch dabei – dass Juve, Inter und Napoli die ersten drei Plätze unter sich ausmachen, weil die einfach zu viel Qualität haben. Aber um Platz 4, würde ich sagen, hast du da wieder ein sehr heißes Rennen, weil da kann auch die Lazio logischerweise lange mitschnuppern. Warum nicht? Also das Potenzial ist definitiv da.
Das hört sich insgesamt nach einer sehr offensiv starken Saison bisher an, in der Serie A. War ja schon was, worüber wir letztes Jahr auch schon gesprochen haben, dass dieses Klischee, was man immer so im Kopf hat, echt nicht mehr so auf die Serie A passt. Aber wenn ich mir so angucke, wie viele Tore erzielt werden, da ging es wahnsinnig ab, schon in den ersten sieben Jahren.
Ja, es gab ja auch schon ein paar verrückte Verhältnisse. Wir hatten es ja schon angesprochen, dieses 4-3 Juve, Napoli, das 4-3 Neapel in Florenz, wo wir auch gleich zu Fiorentina kommen. Also da ist schon einiges gerade nach vorne. Da ist einiges an Spielfreude auch da. Es sind auch viele Trainer, auch wenn man sich die Trainer der Aufsteiger anschaut. Das sind so Trainer, die auch lieber spielen wollen als erstmal sich hinten rein stellen. Deswegen ist das sehr ansehnlich. Ich bin auch sehr gespannt, aber trotzdem, ein Satz von Sarri ist mir nämlich in Erinnerung geblieben. Der hat jetzt auf einer Spieltagspressekonferenz mal gesagt, ja, das stimmt, das ist am Anfang immer so, er hat gemeint, aber schauen wir uns das nach acht, neun Spieltagen an, weil er hat gemeint, dann ist es oft mal so, dass in Italien das am Anfang viel, viel hot ist und alles so ein bisschen versuchen zu zeigen, schau mal, was wir können. Und dann aber irgendwann geht es halt gerade für die Kleine und Fine logischerweise auch immer wieder darum, irgendwie dann doch die Punkte zu holen. Und dann bist du vielleicht halt oft auch auswärts mit dem Unentschieden zufrieden. Aber ich bin völlig bei dir, die ersten Spieltage waren definitiv sehr offensivlastig.
Ja, aber interessanter Punkt, das würde ja durchaus auch Sinn ergeben. Die Lazio spielt auch in der Europa League natürlich. Da ist man in einer Gruppe mit Cluj, Stadträn und Celtic. Da kann man sich glaube ich auch auf das ein oder andere Spiel freuen. Da waren ja auch schon gar nicht so schlechte Begegnungen mit dabei. Dann willst du unbedingt über die Fiorentina sprechen. Warum denn das?
Ich glaube, wir wollen über die Fiorentina sprechen. Ja, ich weiß. In Deutschland wahrscheinlich wegen eines Namens. Keine Frage.
Kevin Pinsporting.
Genau, richtig. Und klar ist Ribery momentan der eine Name, der wirklich das alles bewegt. Aber es ist auch an sich das Konstrukt sehr interessant. Wir können logischerweise sehr gerne bei Herrn Ribery anfangen.
Lass mal damit anfangen. Wie passt denn Franck Ribery rein bei Florenz? Und was ist das für eine Transferpolitik, die die verfolgen? Ich habe den Eindruck, die Fiorentina ist da zumindest in dieser Saison einen anderen Weg gegangen als ganz viele andere Vereine in der Serie A.
Also, dann müssen wir doch beim Großen und Ganzen anfangen. Das macht Sinn. Also, bei der Fiorentina gibt es jetzt seit ein paar Monaten diesen neuen Präsidenten, Commisso, einen US-amerikanischen, schwerreichen, mit italienischen Wurzeln aber schwerreichen Menschen. Und der hat in den Monaten davor sehr viele Töne gespuckt, also groß gesprochen, wo man sich dachte, ja gut, okay, hört sich ganz nett an. Aber, und das muss man jetzt eben auch sagen, der hat im Sommer wirklich auch Taten folgen lassen. Und zum einen beim Kader, aber auch im Umfeld. Die werden jetzt ein neues Sportzentrum bauen. Er will auch unbedingt ein neues Stadion bauen. Also, da ist es wirklich sehr nachhaltig. Der will da wirklich groß investieren. Und hat das Ganze eben auch in der Mannschaft so gemacht. Die Fiorentina ist in der letzten Saison, wer sie vielleicht noch erinnern kann, wirklich haarscharf noch einen Abstieg entdrehen. Die letzten Monate waren unfassbar. Die haben die letzten zwölf Spiele einen Punkt geholt. Oder bis zum letzten Spieltag. Das konnte man sich kaum vorstellen. Die haben im Sommer keinen Stein auf den anderen gelassen. Und haben wirklich aber Qualität dazu geholt. Ribery ist da logischerweise der eine große Name, wo viele am Anfang auch die Nase gerümpft haben. Wie kann man dem zwei Jahre Vertrag geben? Wenn man die ersten Spiele angeschaut hat, dann sieht man, dass Ribery Riesenspielfreude hat. Das ihm auch dieses emotionale südländische Warme sehr gut tut. Der wurde ja schon in Florenz wie ein König empfangen. Also schon bei seiner Ankunft. Das ist schon etwas, was bei solchen Spielertypen auch nochmal was bewegt. Der hat mit Luca Tonia einen engen Freund, der ihm sehr dazu geraten hat, der von der Fiorentina auch zu Bayern gekommen war. Der das Umfeld auch kennt. Florenz ist eine unfassbar emotionale Fußballstadt, die auch immer nur auf so etwas gewartet hat. Wenn das zusammenkommt, dann glaube ich, scharf kommt es eben auch dazu, dass so einer wie Ribery sagt, da haben so viele Menschen in den letzten Wochen und Monaten gemeint, dass das bei mir eigentlich vorbei ist. Denen werde ich nochmal was zeigen. Das letzte Spiel oder vorletzte in Mailand, da hat er Standing Ovations von San Siro bekommen, als er die Milan auseinandergenommen hat. Nicht nur er allein, aber zusammen mit der Fiorentina. Das tut so einem halt gut und ist logischerweise eine der großen Geschichten dieser ersten Serie-Wochen, keine Frage.
Das ist schon echt absolut faszinierend. Und wenn wir uns angucken, wer sonst noch so gekommen ist, dann sehen wir da eben Kevin Prinz Boateng von Sassolo ist noch gekommen, Pedro, ein brasilianischer Mittelstürmer aus Brasilien, kann ich jetzt nur nicht so sagen.
Das sind wirklich sehr viele interessante Namen. Milan Badej kam zurück, der ehemalige Kapitän, der zu der Astoria-Zeit der Kapitän war, der auch sehr verbunden mit der Stadt ist, mit dem Verein. Dalbert kam zum Beispiel von Inter, Madison hat bei Inter da halt eine gewisse Rolle gespielt. Lirola came out of the Swallow, das war auch so einer, der hinter dem die halbe Serie A her war. Und einer, der wahrscheinlich hier auch nicht groß auf dem Radar ist, aber den ich jetzt mittlerweile schon seit ein, zwei Jahren brutal auf dem Zettel habe, ist Eric Pulga, der Chileaner. Der kam aus Bologna für relativ kleines Geld, ich glaube so für um die 10 oder 11 Millionen, weil er so eine Klausel hatte. Und der spielt eine brutale Saison. Der war bei Bologna schon extrem wichtig. Das ist so ein bisschen, so vom Typ her so ein kleiner Vidal-Typ, also wirklich ein sehr dynamischer Mittelfeldspieler.
Spielt ihr auch im defensiven Mittelfeld?
Ja, aber auch geht vorne mit rein. Alle Standards laufen über ihm, hat auch schon zwei oder drei Tore, weil er einen brutal guten Abschluss aus der Distanz auch hat. Das ist so ein Spieler, also wo ich mir denke, wenn du so einen für 10, 11 Millionen kriegst, dann sag ich mal, das geht in die Richtung Schnäppchen des Teares. Weil er hat auch vom Alter her, der Summi 4, 25, also der ist wirklich im richtigen Alter, ist auch schon chilenischer Nationalspieler. Also da ist einfach sehr viel an Qualität dazugekommen und die hat sich jetzt aber auch relativ schnell gefunden. An den ersten Spieltagen sind wir glaube ich drei oder vier Spieltage ohne Sieg geblieben, sind aber ruhig geblieben, haben Chiesa gehalten, logisch ganz wichtig, den wollte halb Europa und den hätte Juve auch alles für den gemacht, aber es war so der erste Satz von Kumisso, warum sollten wir uns einen besseren Spieler hergeben?
Und Chiesa sieht es aber auch so, dass er keine Bälle hat.
Ja, Chiesa hat es im Sommer nicht unbedingt so gesehen, also da gab es schon auch so Geschichten, wo die Frage war, ob er das verkraftet, aber ich glaube, die haben das dem Klippunkt klar kommuniziert. Vielleicht gibt es da schon unterschwellig eine Absprache Richtung nächstes Jahr oder übernächstes Jahr, weil eines ist auch klar, ich glaube, ewig wird einer wie Gieser nicht in Florenz bleiben, weil er wirklich auch für den Sprung reif ist. Aber, wie gesagt, da ist jetzt einfach sehr viel Qualität dazugekommen. Unten muss man auch Montella zugute halten. Er hat es jetzt auch geschafft. Erstmal das Ganze auch in eine sehr gute Richtung. Ich glaube, wir haben jetzt drei Siege in Serie oder vielleicht sogar vier schon. Also die Fiorentina wird definitiv um die europäischen Plätze mitspielen. Keine Frage.
Hat ja auch keine Doppelbelastung. Das wird immer noch ein Vorteil sein. Die letzten drei Spiele eben gewonnen, wie du es gesagt hast, und seit fünf Spielen ungeschlagen in der Serie A. Also auf die Fiorentina, da gucken wir nicht nur wegen Franck Ribery. Wir wollen immer das große Ganze haben. Jetzt haben wir aber auch schon den ersten Trainerwechsel in der Serie A. Beziehungsweise, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es der erste ist bei Milan, ob es noch einen anderen gab, den ich da nicht mitbekommen habe. Bei so einem wie Milan bekommst du halt dann auch mal eine Bushmuth-Riffke. Genau, da kriegt man es mit. Und der Trainer, Nachfolger von Gattuso, durfte selbst jetzt nur – 111 Tage habe ich gelesen – bleiben. Das ist ein Negativrekord. Noch nie musste ein Trainer bei Milan schneller gehen. Warum? Außer, dass er nicht gewonnen hat.
Das ist echt ein schweres Thema. Ich dachte vor der Saison, dass Milan ein bisschen was gelernt hat in den letzten Jahren. Sie haben nicht so viel Geld zu verfügen. Das merkt man einfach, dieses Financial Fair Play. Die haben ja immer noch Auflagen von der UEFA. Von der UEFA.
Was heißt da Gott sei Dank? Aber sie haben ja trotzdem einen Transferminus von fast 64 Millionen. Ihnen waren jetzt nicht komplett die Hände gebunden. Also jetzt nicht so Transferspelten.
Aber da muss man sagen, dass da auch noch einiges an Zahlungen von den Vorjahren drin sind. Also Spieler, die ein Jahr schon da waren und bei denen dann sozusagen eine Kaufpflicht fällig wurde sozusagen. Aber nichtsdestotrotz, fand ich, haben sie ein paar interessante, junge Leute geholt, zum Beispiel Benazir, den Spieler des Afrika-Cups, Spieler des Turniers, der auch mit Algerien den Titel gewonnen hat, der von Empoli kam, hinter dem auch sehr viele her waren. Mit Leao, dem jungen Mittelstürmer Portugiesischen, der jetzt auch schon ganz gut funktioniert hat. Was aber überhaupt nicht funktioniert hat, ist einfach dieses Marco Giampaolo und Milan. Er hat eigentlich einen richtig guten Ruf in Italien, hat über Jahre bei Sampdoria auch davor Stand für sehr organisierten Fußball, auch für offensiven Fußball. Aber die sind einfach nicht zusammengekommen.
War das auch so eindeutig, dass es jetzt sehr gut nachvollziehbar ist, dass man jetzt den Cut gemacht hat? Weil Milan hat das natürlich entsprechend kommuniziert und hat gesagt, ja, das hat einfach nicht gepasst, deswegen mussten wir jetzt den Cut machen, weil wir wollen nicht die Saison jetzt schon wegschmeißen, jetzt haben wir noch genügend Zeit.
Muss man wirklich sagen, glaube ich, in dem Fall war es die richtige Entscheidung, so bitter es für ihn ist. Man darf ja auch nicht vergessen, die Entlassung kam jetzt nach einem Sieg. Milan hatte eigentlich noch gewonnen vor der Pause, aber ich habe das Spiel gesehen in Genua und das war auch wieder 45 Minuten lang, da ging offensiv so gut wie gar nichts. Ich weiß nicht, Milan hat jetzt, schauen wir kurz, sechs Tore. Ja, und sechs waren dann, die zwei waren jetzt da in der zweiten Hälfte von Genua, 11 Meter. Das hat einfach nicht zusammengepasst. Und da war kein Drive nach vorne drin. Man hat sich echt bei jedem Milan-Spiel gefragt, wie wollen die ein Tor schießen? Und das ist dann logischerweise vielleicht in dem Fall dann wirklich, muss man sich vielleicht eingestehen, dass das halt, wie es halt manchmal so ist, dass ein Trainer und ein Umfeld und eine Mannschaft anscheinend halt auch nicht zusammenpassen können. Und ich sag mal so, wenn jetzt Gianpaolo vielleicht bei Parma oder Bologna gewesen wäre, dann wäre das wahrscheinlich halb so wild. Weil dann hätte er mit dieser Punkteanzahl auch noch ein paar Wochen weitermachen können und ich glaube auch, dass der irgendwann sein System vielleicht implementieren hätte können. Aber da hast du logisch bei so einem großen Traditionsverein, wo einfach Druck von Anfang an auf dem Kessel ist, wo ganz andere Ansprüche sind, da war klar, dass das so ein Pulverfass wird und dass er sich wahrscheinlich nicht halten wird können.
Das ist alles sehr gut nachvollziehbar. Auf der anderen Seite würde man ja aber glauben, wenn jemand so früh seinen Trainer wechselt, dann kommt jetzt die Lösung, die total passt. Und jetzt haben wir Stefano Pioli. Der hat das letzte Mal vor 16 Jahren irgendeinen Titel gewonnen. Er hat zwar ganz gute Arbeit gemacht, war ja auch unter anderem bei der Fiorentina, aber direkt nach der Bekanntgabe trendete weltweit das Hashtag Pioli out. Und ohne, dass ich jetzt sagen möchte, Twitter ist da immer der richtige Anhaltspunkt. Aber es zeigt ja, das ist jetzt nicht die große Lösung, wo alle sagen, oh endlich, da konnten wir uns einen richtigen Kandidaten holen, sondern das wirkt jetzt auch ehrlich gesagt wie so, ich weiß nicht, ob Notlösung zu hart ist, aber man musste halt jetzt schnell jemand finden. Jetzt hat man halt Pioli genommen.
Ja, keine Frage. Und du sagst es ja schon, Pioli out. Muss man auch dazu sagen, das war eigentlich weniger auf seine Person bezogen, sondern vielmehr wirklich auf die Vereinsführung. Also ganz viele Milan-Fans. Es gab ja auch diese betrückenden Szenen bei dieser Heimniederlage gegen die Fiorentina, wo ja die Kurva Sud, also die ganze Kurve, Milan Kurve, schon eine Viertelstunde vor Schluss einfach gegangen ist. Und das gab es lange nicht mehr bei Milan. Also da ist einfach eine ganz, ganz tiefe Unzufriedenheit mit dem Verein, wo ganz viele Leute sagen, hey, was habt ihr mit unserem Milan gemacht? Und ich kann mir das – für mich ist es auch schwer zu erklären, weil ich hatte das Gefühl, dass jetzt in den letzten ein, zwei Jahren mit Maldini, der jetzt wieder installiert oder endlich quasi dazu überzeugt werden konnte, wieder in seinen Verein reinzugehen, auch mit Zmoni Miraboban, der jetzt seit dieser Saison dabei ist. Also da ist definitiv Kompetenz da und gerade fußballerische Kompetenz. Aber irgendwie hat das Milan gerade in den letzten Monaten wirklich die Bindung zu den Fans verloren. Und Milan lebt logischerweise auch nicht nur von einer großen Geschichte, sondern auch von dieser engen Verbindung. Die Milan-Kurve steht immer noch für etwas sehr Besonderes im Fußball, auch im Europäischen, auch wenn Milan lang nicht mehr diese Erfolge hat wie noch vor ein, zwei Jahrzehnten. Aber da ist wirklich etwas in die Brüche gegangen. Und da, du sagst es genau richtig, haben sich jetzt einfach ganz viele gefragt, das kann nicht euer Ernst sein. Das mit Gianpaolo hat jetzt nicht funktioniert, okay, aber jetzt holt ihr halt wieder so einen, der halt, ja, dann halt eher dann doch so, sagen wir mal, biederes Mittelding ist. Und ja, es hieß ja, dass sie das Ballett unbedingt wollten. Da ging es anscheinend auch um, der ist ja noch bei Inter unter Vertrag. Da ging es noch um eine Abfindung. Da hat vielleicht Inter auch ein bisschen mitgespielt, gebrokert, dass sie nicht unbedingt wollten, dass der auf der Milan-Bank landet. Ja, und am Ende wird es jetzt Piolli und ja, der hat gleich von Anfang an Megadruck, keine Frage. Also der muss jetzt liefern. Da hilft jetzt nichts anderes, als erst mal, im Idealfall ein paar Siege, um da vielleicht mal ein bisschen Ruhe reinzukriegen. Ja, und dann muss man schauen, wohin das Ganze führt. Aber es ist wirklich, ich muss auch nochmal, ich gebe es offen zu, ich dachte, dass Milan vor der Saison eigentlich schon, sie haben auch mit Hernandez, den Linksverteidiger, geholt, den Bruder von Bayern, Fernandez, da ist schon auch, finde ich, eine gewisse Qualität da. Aber die größte Aufgabe wird wirklich sein, dieses Verhältnis zu den Fans schnellstmöglich zu kitten, denn ansonsten wird es wieder eine ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz schwere Saison für Milan.
Ich finde das so krass, weil man an Inter und Milan geradezu zwei ein Positiv- und ein Negativbild des Fußballs hat. Bei den einen läuft es gerade und du hast das Gefühl, alles klappt im Grunde und vielleicht ist jetzt sogar mal der große Wurf drin. Du hast den Trainer bekommen, den im Grunde eigentlich ganz Italien haben wollte. Und auf der anderen Seite hast du Milan, wo es jetzt überhaupt nicht läuft, die irre Geldprobleme haben. Also Gazzidis, der Vorstandsvorsitzende, ist genauso oft zu lesen wie eben zum Beispiel Maldini oder Boban, weil er immer wieder sich zu den Finanzen äußern muss. Und er sagt so beruhigende Dinge wie Nein, wir sind nicht komplett pleite, macht euch keine Sorgen. Ja, wie soll man sich keine Sorgen machen, wenn das das ist, was du sagst? Und im nächsten Satz sagt er ja, also wir haben auch viele Schulden entdeckt, immer wieder. Und dann hast du bei beiden eine ungeklärte Stadionfrage. Es gibt jetzt Pläne für einen Neubau. Da sagen aber sowohl die Stadt als auch die Anwohner sagen noch, sehen wir jetzt ehrlich gesagt gerade nicht, wie wir das hier realisieren sollen und von uns kriegt er auch kein Geld. Also sprich, die sind ja in derselben Stadt, sie sind im selben Stadion, aber unterschiedlicher könnten diese zwei Welten gerade nicht sein.
Momentan definitiv bin ich voll bei dir, weil gerade dieser Konter-Effekt, der hat wirklich bei Inter nochmal sowas gezündet. Auch Konter hat das auch mal kurz gesagt. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass wir haben die Dynamit-Schnur angezündet. Jetzt geht es darum, darauf auch nachhaltig sozusagen eine Explosion zu entfachen. Und bei Milan hast du halt echt das Gefühl, noch mal, auch dieser Sieg jetzt am Wochenende, aber auch spielerisch war das einfach die ersten Wochen. Du hast dich echt gefragt, das kann nicht Milan sein. Das kann nicht sein. Und dann laufen da ja trotzdem, da laufen so Cialanoglus rum, da läuft Paquetá rum, der ein brasilianischer Nationalspieler ist, da läuft Bilja rum, der in einem WM-Finale stand. Also, das ist ja nicht, dass da...
Da sitzt Ante Rebic auf der Lastbank. Aber das ist ja auch ein Thema für Fans dann. Also, du gibst Silva ab, holst dir dafür Rebic und dann spielt er kaum.
Jaja, klar, der war jetzt am Anfang. Gut, das ist halt so eine Nummer, die in Italien immer wieder vorkommt. Das neue Spiel, die gerade aus dem Ausland kommen, da sind die Trainer manchmal vielleicht übervorsichtig und wollen die nicht zu früh reinwerfen. Gerade bei Rebic aber ist das, finde ich, ein bisschen unverständlich, weil der gerade einer ist, der auch von der Bank kommt, da wirklich auch so einen Impuls setzen kann mit seiner Dynamik. Der ist auch einmal in Verona, wo Milan eines seiner wenigen Spiele gewonnen hat. Gut gemacht hat in der zweiten Halbzeit. Ja, also ich bin sehr gespannt, wie das jetzt unter Piolli funktioniert. Ich würde es ihm wünschen, dass es ein sehr angenehmer Zeitgenosse ist, der auch mit der Fiorentina diese schwierige Phase mit Astoria mitgemacht hat, als ein sehr besonnener Trainer, der auch schon mal kurz bei Inter auf der Bank gesessen ist, also auch der ein bisschen diese Medienwelt in Mailand auch kennt.
Wobei er bei Inter ja auch nicht wirklich erfolgreich war.
Nein, aber da muss man auch dazu sagen, es war die Phase, wo bei Inter keiner erfolgreich war. Das sind ganz andere Trainer eben auch. Das war diese Post-Morino-Phase, wo einfach jeder, der kam, im Prinzip an den Ansprüchen und an den Dingen gescheitert ist. Und ja, ich wünsche ihnen jetzt einfach, dass sie da ein bisschen Ruhe reinkriegen und irgendwie dieses Verhältnis mit den Fans kippen. Weil ja, klar, Milan immer noch einer der großen Namen ist. Ich glaube, er ist einer der großen Traditionsfahnen. Ich glaube, darüber müssen wir nicht diskutieren.
Ach Mensch, die Serie A. Jetzt haben wir wieder nur über die üblich Verdächtigen gesprochen. Wir haben trotzdem schon unsere Stunde voll. Aber die anderen Vereine holen wir mal wann anders nach. Das hat wie immer großen Spaß gemacht, mit dir über die Serie A zu sprechen. Danke dir.
Ja, Max, mir auch.
Bist du sicher nicht irgendwann mal zu Twitter kommen aktuell? Einmal muss ich es noch fragen.
Du hast das schon recht. Ich möchte es nicht ausschließen.
Sehr gut. Das ist mehr, als ich erwarten konnte. Christian Bernhard von DAZN. Wann kann man dich das nächste Mal hören auf DAZN?
Am Wochenende darf ich die italienische Nationalmannschaft gegen Griechenland begleiten. Und in der Woche darauf Juve gegen Bologna.
Das ist jetzt nicht das schlechteste Programm. Also, hört dem Bernie auch auf DAZN zu. Es lohnt sich. Danke dir, dass du hier warst, Bernie.
Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Ja, sehr schön, dass wir wieder über die Serie A sprechen konnten. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war Kurzpass Nummer 137. Wenn ihr es noch nicht gehört habt, dann hört auch mal in unsere Schlusskonferenz zur Bundesliga rein. Und Tribüngespräche gibt es auch. Ein ganz brandfrisches zu den Football Leagues. Und ich verspreche euch, bald kommt schon das nächste. Oh ja. Ich freue mich. Habt eine gute Zeit. Bis bald im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut.